hey cloud developers my name is grant
and my name is vini and we're here to
get you started using Google cloud
functions Google cloud functions makes
it easy to run and scale your code in
the cloud that listens and responds to
events the functions framework lets you
write lightweight functions that run in
many environments including cloud
functions your local development machine
cloud run and cloud run on gke
and k native based environments the
libraries open source on github and the
functions framework is used in a
production by google cloud functions so
grant what is the functions framework
the functions framework defines an
interface for building modular services
this means that rather than emulating
how your function will run in production
you can see exactly how your code will
perform when testing it on your local
machine the functions framework is also
K native compatible sporting kanya of
eventing which makes it possible to port
your functions between k native
environments specifically the functions
framework defines a port for specifying
http functions a target name for the
function and then lastly a signature
type either HTTP our event for the type
of event the functions framework can be
used in two ways either as a CLI a
command line script that you run in your
terminal to start the function server
useful for local testing or as a library
a dependency for your application this
is useful for staging a production
Google Cloud functions environment on
your machine you can specify an explicit
dependency on a version of the functions
framework and if you don't specify a
version Google Cloud functions will
automatically choose the latest
functions framework now let's look at
that open source framework for node it's
used in production for Google Cloud
functions running node 10 within the
package the module uses Express
Express is a fast an opinionated
minimalistic web framework for nodejs
that makes developing services a breeze
it's a project of the node.js foundation
and it's used by the functions framework
let's get started with the functions
framework for no js' let's first run the
command npm install at google - cloud
slash functions framework this will
create a package dot jason in your
current directory create an index jas
file with the following contents so what
are we doing here well we're exporting a
function called hello world the function
accepts two parameters rec for the
express request object and res for the
express response object next we're
sending the string hello world in the
response to start the server run the
following command MPX at google cloud
slash functions framework open localhost
in your browser and see hello world
awesome so you got your function running
on your computer but how do you get it
running in production like it a real URL
good point Vinnie
since the functions framework is the
same library that runs Google Cloud
functions we can deploy our same node
application with no modifications so
let's deploy the code to Google Cloud
functions using G cloud in our directory
with our function we can call G cloud
functions deploy specifying our function
name trigger with HTTP and using node 10
after a bit we'll get a live URL if I
copied the URL and paste it into my web
browser on both my function but where
did our console dot log statements go
fini
well on my machine I'll see the logs in
the terminal where I ran the function
but in the cloud I'll see them on stack
driver this is because Google Cloud
functions has an integration with stack
driver where logs written to standard
out or standard error will
appear directly in cloud console and
that's the Google cloud functions
framework to learn more about the
functions framework check it out on
github you have some useful guides on
how to do things like how to deploy the
cloud run using typescript using the
node debugger etc the link to the github
repo is in the description below and be
sure to subscribe right here on the
Google cloud platform channel on YouTube
to get notified of new videos about
cloud functions we'll see you here next
time
[Music]
you
[Music]